hi i'm nikki and i like to make pizza
because i like to
eat pizza cut we're done go home
so my friend annie has given me a bunch
of pizza making hacks to try
today and we'll see if they work if
they're helpful or
not generally with baking it's really
hard to kind of cut corners which i
think a lot of hacks try to do
so
[Music]
we'll see this is beautiful pizza
and this was made without any of like
the hacks that we're trying i'm using
the
homemade pizza recipe by tasty and
that's what this is
it's like nice and thin but it has like
a nice puffy crust lots of nice
cheese and sauce classic margarita pizza
we're gonna dissolve some yeast into
some water one teaspoon sugar
the recipe calls for two teaspoons of
yeast but our
first hack that we're using says use
three quarters of a teaspoon more yeast
so that it will rise more quickly
this i don't know about generally i
would say follow your recipe
but we're going to try two teaspoons
three quarters more so this is a one
quarter so we got one
two three mix in so it dissolves
and you have to make sure your water is
warm otherwise it won't and it'll just
clump and then it won't dissolve and
your bread won't rise okay so it's been
about 10 minutes that the yeast has been
blooming
in here and i will say looks very yeasty
oh it smells like bread too god yeast is
weird
right what is it next we've got seven
cups of flour
i think this recipe makes like four
pizzas and then i've got six tablespoons
of
olive oil a teaspoon a half of salt so
i'm going to sprinkle salt in with the
flour
and i'm just going to mix this all in
make a little well in the middle
for our wet ingredients to go in and
we're going to throw in the olive oil
right in the middle
wow look at those yeasty bubbles at this
point i would just like
mix this with this wooden spoon but
there's a hack that says you should use
the other end of a spoon
because it's less messy this one i'm
very very uncertain of but
i guess i've never done it so who knows
i would normally use like this end of a
spoon and then when it starts to come
together then start to use my hands i
don't know why this is less messy than
the other side of the spoon so i don't
know about this hack i think it's a
the reason we don't have to use sticks
is because we have spoons i'm kind of
reaching my end here with the spoon so
i'm just gonna use my hands
not a hack just a thing my arm is tired
and there's another hack you can take a
little piece like a maybe like a golf
ball size
and you want to be able to like stretch
it so it becomes like a little window
and then you should be able to like see
light come through it that's how much
you should be able to stretch it without
it tearing
ah look at that nice and stretchy oops a
little tearing don't look at that
i mean it's not great but it'll do so
we're gonna
shape it into a ball and i'm going to
put it in a bowl we're going to grease
the bowl with a little bit of olive oil
and just so the dough doesn't stick and
then at this point you want to let the
dough rest so it can rise and do its
thing
you can wrap this in saran wrap you can
wrap this in like a
kitchen hand towel but there's a hack
that says you can use
a shower cap kitchen towels maybe or
they let too much air in and out they're
like porous
and then this is like not we're just
gonna
the important part is that your dough is
covered i think it's cute
look at how big she is it's been like
two hours the dough's been resting
with this shower cap situation
look at her i wonder if this was the
extra yeast
because it was only two hours and this
has like more than doubled in size
i love how the shower cap made it so
like beautifully round
good job shower cap i just like want to
look at it
bread is so satisfying let me flower my
surface
wait for it there's just a lot of
kneading in this video
were there any kneading hacks that would
have been helpful
okay and then i'm gonna split it into
four because i think this is a recipe to
make four pizzas
okay i've got four little dough portions
and i'm just gonna make them all into
nice neat little balls
if you like to feel things like i do you
should get into making bread because
it's very satisfying i'm just gonna
sprinkle with a little bit of flour
and then they're just gonna rest like
this for about 30 minutes
i wonder if i can use this again does it
look like a chef's hat
while the dough is resting we're going
to make tomato sauce so we've got a can
of tomatoes here
and some salt so usually when you make
tomato sauce it's like easiest to use
canned tomatoes that's what i do as well
this is a can of whole tomatoes and they
usually come in like a liquid
and one of the hacks which i don't know
again if it's really a hack it's like a
thing you probably should do
just recommends draining the liquid
because canned tomatoes can have a lot
of excess
liquid a lot of excess water and i'm
just gonna open the can of tomatoes and
drain the liquid be careful with your
fingies
oh there they are whole peeled tomatoes
generally you want to be draining liquid
from canned tomatoes anyway so
i guess like yes this is a hack but also
it's like a thing you should do and then
we're just going to add a tablespoon of
salt
and then we're going to blend it
this is like nice and chunky and not too
liquidy
this is like salty tomatoes tomato sauce
has it been 30 minutes do you think
oh so puffy puffy babies at this point
you would like
maybe re-flour the surface and then like
squidge this until it becomes a pizza
shape one of the hacks says to use
semolina flour
instead of regular ap flour because it
gives it like a little bit of like a
texture and also when it bakes it
doesn't like stick so much to it
flour has like a taste you know when you
like get a pizza or something and
there's just like flour on the bottom
there's like a so we're gonna use some
semolina flour oh it's like very fine
too we're just gonna slowly turn her
into
pizza this is like the situation right
semolina flour everywhere nice looking
i think when you like buy pizza at like
a restaurant sometimes what can make the
baking process really nice is they have
like a pizza stone
it's basically there's like this big
stone that gets really hot in the oven
you can put pizza on top of it
bake and get nice and crusty there's
this other hack where you can bake it on
an upside down like cookie sheet
and that will be your big hot pizza
stone so we're gonna bake it on an
upside down cookie sheet and it needs to
be preheated so i'm just putting that in
the preheated oven
it's like a very clean oven has anyone
used that yet
our pizza stone upside down baking sheet
is in the oven
um and so i'm gonna transfer the dough
onto this
now in restaurant then fancy pizza
people have like pizza peels
isn't that one right there if you don't
have a pizza peel
you can just use like a chopping board
so that's what we're gonna do no pizza
peel
no problem it's literally just in the
background
i don't have one at home so it's okay i
have a cutting board at home so just use
what you have
okay so i'm just gonna put semolina on
the chopping board so it doesn't stick
yay she's pretty not the toppings
one of the hacks and annie's hack sheet
says to spread on the tomato sauce but
not too much
when you spread the sauce on you should
still be able to see the dough
underneath
i think cause the thinking is that sauce
is like wet
and it can be like soggy no one likes
soggy pizza
well i'm sure someone does i've spread
the sauce
and i can still see the dough cheese
time my favorite time
mozzarella usually comes in this liquid
to keep it fresh
and soft because you don't want
mozzarella to dry out so we've got some
kitchen paper look at these cute little
pillows of cheese
i love cheese telling people really got
this right okay
geez done there's another hack on here
that says
[Music]
so there's another hack that says you
should only have like three toppings on
your pizza because
that's like the right amount of toppings
listen
put whatever the [ __ ] you want to put on
your own pizza okay you want to put 12
toppings on there do it
you're eating it annie didn't get me any
toppings so we've got basil so some
people will put olive oil on before
um or some people will put it on after i
think really it's just personal
preference
sometimes i do a little bit of both
we're being honest mickey hack
olive oil whenever you feel like it i
made a pizza so now we'll go slide this
onto our upside down cookie tray
this as my pizza peel should just slide
the pizza right onto the
hot baking stone
oh this makes me nervous
oh you know what that worked out pretty
well
it was a pretty easy transition good
hack
pizza pie i'm just gonna do another
quick
tiny little dissolve all a while yeah
okay another hack says to just tear
basil with your hands instead of using
scissors but
who is cutting basil with scissors okay
i hacked the pizza i think this upside
down cookie sheet worked out really well
this is hot before you put the pizza on
it so the underneath gets nice and
hot and crispy right away instead of
baking it on a sheet that
has to get hot while the pizza is
getting hot at the same time so
good hack the semolina flour like helped
it not stick too badly
and i think it gives it like a little
bit of a crunch because it's like a more
textured flour another hack is to use
scissors to cut pizza
it's like yeah why not i feel like asian
people like to use scissors to cut
everything in the kitchen
so this is like this makes a lot of
sense to me if you were like oh
an asian grandma made this hack i'd be
like yeah can i eat it now
it's steamy
so hot
[Music]
heck if your pizza's too hot blow on it
[Music]
that's really good not too much sauce
very nice
crispy crust not soggy at all it needs
salt
tomatoes are naturally very sweet now
that i'm like eating it eating it
i don't love all of the semolina on the
bottom it is like a texture you can
feel it in your mouth it's like a little
bit sandy the last pizza hack
apparently if you're looking for an
alternative way to
reheat your pizza you can use a waffle
iron
so i'm just gonna cut a kind of a big
piece and then you're supposed to like
fold it and then put it in a waffle iron
[Music]
this feels silly so i guess if you're
like
i need this pizza hot and crispy now you
can whip out your waffle iron
whoa very hot and melty
does it work yes would i do this
no this is so much work now i have to
clean my waffle iron so here are my
three favorite pizza hacks from today
one the shower cap oh that was very
effective two
using the upside down cookie tray as a
pizza stone three the
chopping board as the pizza peel having
that chopping board
was really helpful with the semolina it
just slid right off i have done it in
the past and it's been very messy
the fact that it wasn't messy this time
i think is a great hack grazia
foreign